der nächste bitte ich werde aber Zeit
ich warte schon ewig deine Zeitschriften
habe ich jetzt schon zwei mal durch und
bloß als Tipp in deiner neuesten
Zeitschrift da draußen da steht drin
dass der jopi ist das und die Simone
Rethel demnächst heiraten wollen was
fällt uns denn was uns fehlt was uns
fehlt
aber ich höre schlecht und das ist in
letzter Zeit immer schlimmer geworden
inzwischen wäre ja fast gar nichts mehr
na dann schauen wir mal
dann schauen wir mal
[Musik]
was ist das denn Ingwer
es ist schon früh besser
drehen sie sich rum
[Applaus]
frei hat der Ingwer doch Käufer mit
Großmutter schon immer gesagt es bis die
Hausmittel für
immer und was sonst kommt
nie wieder zu mir machen eine wunderbare
Ingwer schmankerlplatten